the part that nobody talks about the key
is to be happy with yourself
not in request the phantom working for
us but the viewers have put in the work
you're so [ __ ] fancy like I have no
interest in making you happy about my
work-life balance
you worry about your work-life balance
like my key is first me and this is in
order then my kids have my wife because
if I'm happy then I can do anything for
them and that's it right and that's what
I that's what matters
[Music]
it's going hard on my Indian content oh
did you hear about the dubbing you miss
that we're looking for you in a meeting
it's crazy
cleaner mentors going to be happy
no excited
like getting weekly know if somebody was
like like at 100,000
[Music]
[Music]
when I was younger I was
it's that one meeting it's worth those
ten hours of executional work times a
hundred
so what experience teaches you or is
that that it's that you know it's funny
as I get older I'm getting more patient
even in a way because of the time like I
went through that it might look good
since I've known you missus yeah and
that early mid 30s
I was like I was patient because I
learned in those 12 years yeah
compact
[Music]
buster
one meaning that matters
[Music]
I never posted that are not answered it
did
[Music]